hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome tell
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of my readers
Marty's who wrote in saying hey Evan
this is Marty Armstrong was wondering if
you could review my blog I seen we
getting good traffic and ideas and how
it can make it even stronger clear I'm
more effective in getting more leads
perhaps would love your ideas mortise PS
i know the picture is horrible but that
should be changing soon so let's check
out the website and see what kind of
feedback we can give for Marty's so this
is the website tremenda life marketing
how to get real results in network
marketing so my first thought is that
you need to get a better design the
design is is pretty poor here if you're
even just using a simple wordpress setup
and you don't have to be a text are to
be able to use wordpress you can use
word you can use wordpress i get set up
on wordpress it's easy to edit easy to
update and you can get a theme either
for free or 50 100 bucks you get a nice
theme it looks really professional that
would be a really good start to given
you a professional theme and look around
around this website the next thing we
look at is your logo again it's a it
looks homemade and you know good to have
t l don't know what tremenda tremenda
life it necessarily means but if that's
fine to have it as your your your logo
but you might want to experiment with
getting somebody to help you create your
logo you can look at something like 99
designs cost you maybe 200 bucks to have
a professional logo made and people from
around the world would bid on it and
give you some some design ideas the goal
here so here's my challenge the main one
with it you try to position yourself as
an expert right how to get real results
in network marketing so we want to be
like you right if somebody is starting a
network marketing ideally they want to
be like you right so this web page has a
scream success if you want people to
follow you and think of you as being a
success in network marketing you need to
showcase yourself as being too
successful and having a design and a
look that's successful this this isn't
screaming it to me you write the picture
of the picture picture could use some
work it's not that about a picture and
that you know your your sweater you got
a nice file it's just really low quality
right it's hard to see your face clearly
so you do want to improve that picture
where we through hello entrepreneurs is
Marty so on a person welcome to my blog
you'll find tips techniques a great
business exponentially little more money
its invest good if you're ready students
to be long and above if not and I
provide some free information for you on
the blog and be expecting the link ok so
the blog here we'll check out keep
checking the blog periodically be
posting a regular basis ok great am I
crazy probably but beyond my girl right
now to give everyone everybody who's
sincere and opportunity to learn step by
step what every system network marketers
should know I give them a real chance at
success not just to help I really like
this this is really good this is an
awesome statement it it sounds genuine
there's value in there for the for the
people who are visiting the site I try
to make all of your messaging around
this kind of this kind of warden I like
you tag line to how to get real results
in network marketing again it doesn't
fit with the theme and design of your
website if you were getting really
strong results in network marketing I
wouldn't expect you know this is your
logo this is your website and this is
your picture so you want to have that
brand as being a successful entrepreneur
and that comes from having a nice design
as well here we get free audio training
leave a reply post a comment you know
one like it's not going to be great
that's kind of buried at the bottom I
probably take that off or if you're
gonna have it then have it more
prominently placed and do promotion to
get you know you're at least your
friends to like the page so when
somebody visit this site doesn't look
like there's nobody visiting it let's go
up to look at your blog since that's
what you're talking about here
and it's okay tremenda life marketing
how to get real results so the same
thing appears you secret to accomplish
anything you want let's click on that so
you're telling us on your homepage to
check back in the blog regularly to just
you know checking out updates and right
now it's it's what let me check the date
here it's it's April tenth and your last
update was november 18 2012 so it's
april 20 2013 right now so it's been a
long time since you've updated this this
blog but it looks like you're you're
adding great content so there's you're
not just putting fluff in here and
you're not just promoting affiliate
links like a lot of these guys would do
like this post goes on this is this is
pretty good they don't like the Michael
Jordan quote there at the end I would
make sure you're posting more have a
strong call to action so that's great
somebody lands on this post they're all
pumped up they think they can accomplish
anything they want what do I do next
right how do I sign up with you for your
newsletter or get on your training
program or your mentorship program or
whatever it is you know you want to have
that as a clear call to action s or
somebody's right through this article so
I think you're you're on the right track
in terms of your content creation it's
really making this site look better look
like you're a success and investing some
money into your design and your logo to
make sure that that message comes across
having that better picture having
stronger calls to action on your pages
and then making sure you keep up with
your content schedule you know you want
to be posting at least every month on
this blog ideally every week to have
people come back and build an audience
and get them to take action on whatever
it is that you want them to do next so
hopefully that helped those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below and if you
have a comment about this website or
question for your own business feel free
to leave in the comments section below I
always read those I love seeing them
come in they always make my day so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode
you